bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne
l'audition du président directeur
général d'air france alexandre de juniac
il est entendu par les sénateurs dans un
contexte très particulier puisque lundi
le groupe franco néerlandais numéro deux
européen des transports aériens a
annoncé une seconde cure d'austérité
après celles déjà lancé en juillet
dernier le groupe doit en effet réduire
sa dette de 2,6 milliards d'euros durant
les deux prochaines années pour
atteindre une rentabilité de 6 à 8% en
2015 ce qui lui permettrait de se
rapprocher du niveau de ses concurrents
un effort jugé donc indispensable par le
groupe compte tenu du contexte de
compétitivité accrue et de hausse du
prix du pétrole
il se traduira par la suppression
d'environ 8000 postes dont 5000 chez air
france des suppressions qui s'ajouteront
aux 1300 postes déjà supprimés cette
année tout de suite donc direction la
salle clemenceau pour l'audition du
président directeur général d'air france
très bonne matinée à tous sur public
sénat nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
donc monsieur alexandre de juniac
président directeur général d'air france
depuis novembre 2011 et donc sur le
président directeur général on peut dire
que vous pilotez l'homme des fleurons de
l'économie française et donc à ce titre
là c'est sûr que vous avez je crois à
faire face à une période qui va vous
amener à faire des économies puisque air
france a perdu 350 millions l'an passé
et pourrait tempérer un peu plus cette
année alors que le trafic a repris et
que le chiffre d'affaires augmente donc
vous avez lancé un plan de redressement
ambitieux transforme une 2015 pour
rétablir les marges bénéficiaires
dès 2015 et remettre en selle une
compagnie aérienne globale c'est-à-dire
présente à l'international aux
régionales et sur le même segment low
cost avec de rossi
on peut dire qu'on n'avait pas perdu de
temps que vous avez immédiatement pour
l'émission qui ont pour but de réduire
les dépenses en particulier le gel des
salaires
vous avez également donc renégocier des
accords sociaux et vous avez également
procédé à des restructurations de
l'offre industrielle et bien sûr
vous essayez de mettre un ordre de
marche lente de route
ce fleuron par rapport à vos concurrents
européens entre autres vous avez annoncé
550 millions d'euros d'investissements
supplémentaires pour améliorer la
qualité de ses services au sol et en
cabine et vous prévoyez le départ
volontaire d'environ 5 mhz une centaine
de postes qui vont répondre à cet
objectif que vous êtes fixé un gain de
productivité de 20% pour chacune des
trois catégories du personnel donc les
premiers effets de ce plan qui je
suppose a fait l'objet d'une négociation
âpre difficile et peut-être que vous
présenterez vos collaborateurs dont on
m'avait dit il joué un rôle important se
traduisent par un accord qui est déjà
signé de la part des pilotes et du
personnel au sol les navigants
commerciaux ont pas encore donné leur
accord mais devrait peut-être se
prononcer rapidement et donc tout ceci
va peut-être faire l'objet si vous le
bien d'une présentation et peut-être que
vous pouvez nous donner un petit peu le
point de set
difficile négociation certes mais
certainement indispensable
en gros nous aimerions savoir si vous
pensez pouvoir limiter les pertes dès
l'année prochaine
et bien sûr quel est le devenir des
lignes déficitaires puisqu'un certain
nombre de territoires et c'est là que
notre compétence aménagement du
territoire nous rendent très curieux
comment voyez vous l'évolution de ses
lignes intérieures
quand elles sont déficitaires en gros
tout savoir
voilà donc si vous voulez bien nous
présenter vos collègues et ensuite vous
présenter et nous faire une petite
présentation cette situation des routes
sur le président mesdames et messieurs
les membres de la commission d'avoir
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir ce matin
je suis venu avec un à droite donc à
vivre c'est acquis et le directeur
général adjoint en charge des ressources
humaines et donc qui a piloté l'ensemble
des chantiers sociaux qui sont une des
conditions nécessaires de notre succès
zoran junkie qui s'occupe de l'ensemble
des cryptes de direction au cabinet du
d'air france et puis patricia manom qui
gère les relations avec notamment le
monde parlementaire et cette assemblée
en particulier avant peut-être de
répondre à vos questions je je je
suggère le parrain main par un propos
introductif j'évoque devant vous
l'évolution de l'industrie du transport
aérien mondial
d'une part d'autre part la position
d'air france klm au sein de cette
industrie et enfin le plan que que nous
mettons en oeuvre et la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons donc premier
point si vous le voulez bien l'industrie
du transport aérien mondial c'est une
industrie qu'on peut caractériser la
manière suivante une industrie fragile
fragile et qui est en difficulté
notamment en europe
c'est une industrie fragile parce que
c'est une industrie qui cumule deux de
deux caractéristiques que vous
connaissez bien sans doute c'est une
intensité capitalistique extrêmement
forte
puisqu'il faut acheter des avions il
faudra des infrastructures lourdes
qu'elles soient industrielles ou ou
nous-mêmes informatique
donc pour vous donner un chiffre la
valeur à neuf
de la flotte du groupe air france klm
c'est une vingtaine de milliards d'euros
ne faut pas se tromper dans la zone
vestissement bouffer service man
extrêmement lourd valeur à neuf je
précise pour donner un ordre de grandeur
elle elle cumule deuxième
caractéristique c'est une c'est une
industrie à forte intensité de main
d'oeuvre puisque dans le fond c'est une
industrie de services
même si air france klm est aussi un
employeur industriel devant 15000
emplois industriels
air france klm 1 on a des gros employeur
industriel dans les reer au nautic le le
le le principal la principale fraction
de nos emplois surtout n'ont pas de
service service à bord ou services cargo
donc c'est une c'est une industrie qui
est une industrie structurellement
employeurs de main-d'oeuvre
ce qui n'est je ne porte pas de jugement
sur ce point mais qui en termes de
concurrence internationale et sa
deuxième caractéristique qui explique sa
difficulté en termes de concurrence à
seurre et une jupe très exposé nous
sommes exposés à la concurrence
internationale et ce jour est
caractérisée de plusieurs manières
nous sommes exposés à la concurrence
internationale en europe puisque
l'europe a complètement ouvert à tous et
mende et réguler ce marché comme vous le
savez est là la principale concurrence
auxquelles nous nous devons faire face
l'éruption extrêmement rapide des low
cost que vous vivez j'imagine aussi dans
l'ensemble de vos régions et territoires
il faut le savoir qu'en france nous
avons été relativement protégé
d'ailleurs du fait de la de la position
du positionnement important d'air france
puisque la part de marché des low cost
et 20% en france est en moyenne de 40 %
en europe
il ya des pays où elle dépasse 50 où
elle atteint même 60 % c'est le cas de
l'espagne de l'italie
voilà deux de première catégorie
concurrence deuxième catégorie de
concurrence nous nous voyons arriver sur
le long-courrier des compagnies qu'une
bulle qui n'existait pas il ya une
dizaine d'années ce sont les compagnies
du golfe que vous connaissez sans doute
emirates qatar
etihad nous voyons arriver les
compagnies asiatiques avec dédé
des flottes noël sont plus loin sur plus
en bout de ligne donc ce qu'il nomme une
coopération avec elle un peu plus facile
mais enfin la concurrence y compris son
long courrier se renforce et elle-même
menadi et c'est vrai en europe
c'est vrai aussi dans le monde
international qu'elle est très très dur
parce que pour des entreprises de
services fortement employeurs de
main-d'oeuvre nous sommes statuts
sociaux contre statuts sociaux avec les
avantages les inconvénients liés à sa
situation qui ne faut voir qu'il ne faut
pas négliger y compris en europe y
compris en europe puisque je sais pas
devant cette assemblée que je vais le
leur et l'harmonisation fiscale et
sociale n'est pas encore totalement
réalisées sur le continent comme comme
comme vous le savez donc c'est une
industrie qui est donc fragile elle est
en difficulté récurrente puisqu'elle est
soumise à très nombreux aléas vous
connaissez la météo mais on ignorait la
patte d'un volcan encore qui a arrêté le
trafic aérien pendant plusieurs jours le
temps des dizaines de millions centaines
de millions à l'ensemble de l'industrie
du transport aérien
les désastres technologique de type
fukushima qui ont bloqué le marché
japonais par exemple pour nous et puis
et puis bien sûr des difficultés
géopolitiques par exemple le printemps
arabe a arrêté pratiquement le trafic
sur la partie et disons un moyen-orient
afrique du nord où elle a énormément
ralenti donc séduit afrique est fragile
elle est en difficulté notamment en
europe
ce n'est pas le cas partout les
compagnies américaines maintenant ce
sont pratiquement tout redresser après
être tout passé je le précise ce qu'on
appelait chapitre 11 toutes les quatre
grandes sont passés en chapitre 11
les mais maintenant ce que connaissent
une situation qui est beaucoup plus
favorable en asie beaucoup des
compagnies sont nationales et attisé ou
sondés pseudopode de leur état c'est le
cas les compagnies chinoises par exemple
ça n'est pas le cas les compagnies
japonaises mais je vous rappelle que la
jal japan airlines est passé aussi pour
une situation de quasi faillite et les
compagnies du golfe bénéficient disions
dada d'un actionnaire et d'un soutien
actionnariale extrêmement fort et pour
lequel en tout cas la rentabilité du
capital n'est pas toujours la première
des priorités
mais ce qui est et et sont aussi
l'expression de la puissance ou
développement économique
des différents états qui les qui les
possèdent ce soit le qatar les émirats
arabes unis où la partie enfin parti a
boudé bio partie dubaï
donc ce sont des ce2 dans le reste du
monde les compagnies se porte
disons pas trop mal mais bénéficie aussi
d'un soutien d'un environnement
particulièrement favorable en europe
c'est moins le cas
les grandes compagnies majeures c'est à
dire british airways iberia d'une part
lufthansa qui est qui qui vous savez et
avec swiss et sabena technics seule
bonne note nos concurrents et air france
klm sont en situation difficile ou et
vous avez vu on lance les plans de
restructuration extrêmement vigoureux
c'est le cas de iberia extrêmement fort
1 une reçu de façon extrêmement forte
c'est vrai de lufthansa avec ses
filiales germanwings notamment avec
austrian et donc le le transport et en
europe se portent disons de manière
extrêmement fragile avec la disparition
d'acteurs qui existaient jusque là je
vous rend si tu es 2 depuis le depuis
mon arrivée à la france ces deux êtres
européens ont disparu il était certes de
taille limitée mais c'est important
c'était malev la compagnie hongroise
nationale qui a disparu et spanair
company compagnie espagnole qui était
plus une compagnie de type d'unions semi
low cost pour pour rêver pour la
caractériser et de nombreuses compagnies
européennes sont encore dans des
situations difficiles notamment dans les
pays disons de de tapie donc c'était le
transport aérien européen est en
situation difficile or comme vous le
savez cette industrie est clé pour les
pays qui en disposent notamment pour la
france
on dit toujours je crois que c'est exact
il n'y a pas de grands pays se rendront
pas guérir puisqu'il est il est très
difficile évidemment d'organiser le
transport international que ce soit des
passagers et des marchandises des hommes
d'affaires et à sang avoir une compagnie
qui est qui est un réseau mondial
à ce titre c'est mon second point air
france klm est un est un acteur est un
acteur majeur majeurs 1 dans cette
industrie transport aérien mais elle est
dans une situation financière qui est
extrêmement tendue extrêmement tendue et
c'est ce qui a exigé ce que vous avez
rappelé monsieur le président c'est à
dire ces sept sur des mesures de
redressement très vigoureuse lors d'un
acteur majeur quelques éléments pour
caractériser un nous avons entre air
france et klm à peu près 600 avions
ainsi donc l'une des première compagnie
mondiale en terme de nombre d'avions
nous sommes nous sommes probablement
dépassé par des compagnies américaines
je pense que delta youn a été d'un
nombre d'avions supérieur au nôtre mais
après ce doit être nous pas très loin
avec lufthansa lufthansa
c'est le plus grand réseau
intercontinental mondiale nous
desservons près de 130 destinations dans
le monde
quand le deuxième réseau qui est celui
de lufthansa en dessert un peu moins de
100 donc nous connecte tout ce que nous
avons l'habitude de dire en bon français
conect et connect europe with the world
c'est ce que c'est ce que fait
air france klm en offrant le maximum de
destinations
c'est aussi parce que nous appartenons
un réseau d'alliances très puissant qui
le le réseau skyteam avec deux très
grands partenaires principaux dans la
partie américaine delta donc qui es-tu
maintenant la première pour leur bonne
exécution le continent nord-américain et
de deux grandes compagnies chinoises je
parle de grands partenaires en termes de
nationalité
et puis de grande compagnie chinoise
china eastern et china southern
ce qui donne nous donne l'accès à ce que
à ce qui va être bientôt le plus grand
marché aeria du monde qui est le marché
chinois mais auxquels s'ajoutent les
coréens des compagnies européennes des
accords que nous avons avec des
compagnies sud américaine pour tout ça
pour offrir à travers skyteam
parce que c'est un avantage commercial
et stratégique majeur un nombre de
destinations le plus le plus commode et
le plus accessible possible que nous
demandent nos clients notamment nos
clients que ceux qui sont les grandes
entreprises mondiales qui ont besoin de
voir un réseau important donc un acteur
majeur
air france klm en france c'est un acteur
évidemment très très très important pour
plusieurs raisons j'ai ensuite je les
cite sans sens sans préoccupation
d'importance nous sommes d'abord le
premier employeur privé de la région ile
de france
de france nous avons ainsi tel
pratiquement quarante cinq mille francs
pratiquement 45 mille salariés sur
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
entre roissy et orly principalement qui
sont nos deux nos deux grands pôles
d'activité de la région ile de france
nous sommes un acteur je crois important
l'aménagement du territoire grâce à la
fois à nos dessertes opérés par air
france ou opérés par les compagnies
régionales que vous connaissez régional
brit air air linair je crois qu'on est
aussi un acteur important en matière
industrielle air france industries ses
9000 emplois industriels de très hautes
qualifications dans le cadre de la
maintenance ce n'est pas une anecdote un
air france klm engineering maintenance
et de noël c'est le nom de ce que nous
avons donné à cette entité pour air
france klm c'est le numéro 2 mondial
après après lufthansa de la maintenance
industrielle qui était qui comme vous le
savez sur développe extrêmement vite
puisque la fois
mondiale croît dans des proportions très
rapide parallèlement au transport aérien
donc donc air france klm est un acteur
majeur à plusieurs titres
je rappelle ses 25 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires 700 milles à plus de
cent mille cent sept mille salariés air
france représentant deux tiers de ce
total au sein d'air france klm
mais malheureusement c'est une pression
financière qui est très dégradé
peut-être de deux éléments pour le polo
caractérisée nous nous nous avons subi
plusieurs années de pertes
air france a subi cinq années de pertes
consécutives des pertes d'exploitation
non perte d'exploitation quand on évoque
quand on a déjà perdu de l'argent
l'exploitation c'est pas nous c'est pas
cette commission je veux dire qu'on n'a
même pas en plus payer les intérêts de
notre dette financière donc c'est
vraiment très grave et d'autre part et
et pour 2012
notre perte d'exploitation qui
normalement devrait être inférieur à
c'est à dire sur nenon nous sommes
engagés vis-à-vis de la communauté
financière restera tout de même
significative très significative
et ça c'est donc le premier indicateur
second indicateur se discute et
financiers à notre dette financière qui
s'élevait à peu près entre 2 et 2
milliards et demi en 2007 a pratiquement
triplé puisque nous atteignons 6
milliards et demi à la fin 2011 au 31
décembre 2011
je rappelle que cette dette financière
cette aide financière purement
financières auxquelles s'ajoutent les
leasing d'avions qui sont une pratique
normale de l'industrie donc il n'ya pas
lieu non plus de nini de surévaluer me
faut en tenir compte et que avec le
leasing d'avions notre dette totale
s'élèverait aux alentours de 11
milliards d'euros
donc c'est par rapport à des fonds
propres qui s'établissent à 5 milliards
vous voyez qu'on est dans une situation
qui commence à être très difficile c'est
d'autant plus difficile que comme vous
le savez et j'aurais peut-être dû
mentionner avant le fait que nous soyons
à forte intensité capitalistique afin
d'inciter de manoeuvre et à forte
concurrence fait que nous fait que nous
faisons démarche extrêmement limité
c'est une industrie à très gros volumes
les cours et derrière on est très gros
chiffre d'affaires dont tout le monde
s'imagine que nous le sommes très bien
très très très puissant mais
malheureusement ne faisant pas de marge
c'est cette année de mon petit peu
triste de cette de cette industrie en
nous on démarche très réduits ce qui
donc caractérise la fragilité financière
et vous explique pourquoi ce cas
l'endettement important est un élément
extrêmement préoccupant chez au sens
large
évidemment le tout toutes contraintes
financières se ressent beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus vivement
ceci donc cédé situation financière
impose un redressement un redressement
très vigoureux nous avons nous avons
lancé un plan doit se montrer rigoureux
il s'appelle transforme 2015 je vais
lancer dès mon arrivée c'est à dire en
janvier dernier avec un ensemble de
mesures immédiates
vous l'avez rappelé le président gel des
salaires compression des investissements
coupes dans les dépenses dans les
dépenses de frais généraux
donc ça c'est un petit peu du très
classique même si c'est pas très
agréable c'est une très classique puis
nous avons lancé tout un ensemble un
autre ensemble de mesures qui étaient
fondés sur trois volets et je vais venir
tout de suite un volet industriel un
volet social
un volet commercial donc ce plan de
redressement est vigoureux ce set s'est
mu adoration yougov fait l'objet d'un
plan c'est mon troisième point donc un
plan de retour à la profitabilité est de
retour au premier plan de la compagnie
air france et air france klm bien sûr
dans son sillage de au premier plan en
termes de positionnement commercial de
marque de positionnement de qualité de
produit donc c'est un plan ambitieux qui
a trois volets restructurations
industrielles importantes en vue
d'augmenter notre compétitivité
re négociation sociale des de l'ensemble
des accords régissant les conditions
d'emploi de nos des différentes
catégories de personnels hank est une
condition nécessaire pas suffisante mais
nécessaire du succès en vue d'atteindre
20 % de gains de productivité
et puis troisièmement une reconquête
commerciale de notre de notre notre
marché dont premier volet
restructuration industrielle en vue
d'augmenter la compétitivité
le un des points clés qui expliquent la
dégradation des résultats d'air france
c'est une structure de coûts qui est
trop élevé notamment par rapport à nos
principaux concurrents et je ne voudrais
pas ici qu'on nous comparer à des les
concurrents pour lequel la comparaison
ne serait pas raisonnable ou serait tout
serait biaisée je parle de concurrents
européens de type lufthansa ou british
airways donc des pays
disons que nous pourrions qualifier de à
droits sociaux à peu près équivalent ou
avec des des conditions réglementaires
fiscales et sociales qui même s'ils ne
sont pas comparables tout à l'heure ne
ne ne porte pas de différence excessive
dans une structure de coûts beaucoup
trop élevé ce qui nous a amenés à faire
un plan industriel qui est fondée sur
l'idée suivante optimiser le long
courrier
nous avons dans le long courrier comme
je le dis un réseau très dense c'est
plutôt une partie qui fonctionne pas
trop mal chez air france mais qui a
perdu en compétitivité mais
commercialement elle marche bien nous
avions sont pleins
la recette se maintient à peu près
correctement sur des vols
intercontinentaux meinau nos coûts étant
un peu élevé la baisse des coûts fera
que nous reviendrons une profitabilité
très significatif selon cru et quand
nous sommes maintenant à 0 on est à 0
sur le long-courrier 0 plus disons alors
que ça a longtemps été une des sources
importantes de profitabilité d'air
france et d'air france klm et d'air
france hors paris bull donc optimisation
du long courrier
une restructuration beaucoup plus
importants du court et du moyen courrier
qui concentrent l'intégralité des pertes
dans l'activité passage d'air france klm
d'air france en particulier ses 700
millions d'euros de pertes au total 500
pour air france 200 plants klm est donc
ccc c'est là que se concentre la
restructuration industrielle par la mise
en place de deux catégories de mesures
d'une part une optimisation de notre
programme viendra leur monsieur le
président nous avons fait fermer des
lignes ouvertes et enfin dans mon à
restructurer les lignes en fermant des
lignes déficitaires en essayant d'ouvrir
des lignes sur des destinations que nous
pensons bénéficiaires ça c'est pour
l'ensemble du réseau
deuxièmement nous avons restructuré
notre offre trouve
ra pôles un pôle air france que vous
connaissez qui opère sous les couleurs
d'air france qui dessert les grands flux
de trafic que ce soit depuis orly où
depuis roissy sur les villes de province
sur les villes de province française et
sur quelques villes européennes
un pôle qu'on appelle le pôle régional
français la nouvelle marque sera dévoilé
fin janvier je peux pas encore vous la
donne et puisque nous sommes en test
d'antériorité dont jeu
voilà qui est qui va servir à la fois
l'alimentation d'orly et de roissy sur
les petits flux de trafic mais aussi les
lignes transversales à partir des villes
de province
donc indispensable à l'aménagement du
territoire ne vous le connaissez bien
ce pôle âge là le français regroupant
les anciennes filiales que vous
connaissez britair régional
airlinair et puis un troisième pôle tes
transactions qui est un pôle low cost
qui est notre filiale pour adresser ce
marché low cost qui y croient qui est le
marché le plus actuellement le plus
dynamique et le marché du loisir rapport
au marché affaire qui est beaucoup plus
qui souffrent davantage et pour lequel
donc nous espérons donc adressé avec
cette offre combinée l'ensemble les
segments de marché donc voilà le là les
éléments de restructuration industrielle
de notre plan alors je passe sur le feu
ce fait transférer des vols de roissy à
orly faire tourner davantage nos avions
c'est un jeu mais je suis tout à fait
prêt à répondre aux questions plus
détaillées vous voudrez bien me me
pousse
deuxième aspect la renégociation
sociales condition nécessaire du succès
s'être négociations sociales a été lancé
dès le mois de février mars dernier à
dessiner sur les trois catégories de
personnel personnel au sol personnel
navigant commercial c'est-à-dire les
hôtesses et stewarts personnel navigant
technique pilotes nous nous étions
deniers plus que de deux objectifs
d'abord un objectif commun qui était de
la réduction de 20% des coûts de chacune
des catégories de personnel et
deuxièmement le terminer dans un délai
de trois mois donc à conteuses ont comme
on a ouvert officiellement fin mars
les négociations se devait d'être
terminés fin juin ce qui était pas
totalement la tradition de la maison qui
s'est un petit peu plus
jean dans la dans la longueur grâce
grâce à mon voisin de droite
tout le mérite lui en revient de
négociation sur trois ont abouti avec
grand succès c'est à dire atteignant les
20 % et dans les trois mois avec
l'épisode d'une part et avec le
personnel au sol l'autre pas je rappelle
que c'est important puisque le personnel
au sol représentent 60 % de nos
effectifs
les pilotes représentent beaucoup moins
nos effectifs mais comme vous le savez
sont une part extrêmement critique
on ne peut pas nier aérienne extrêmement
importante et donc ce sont deux
catégories de population dès qu'il était
devant clé de réussir malheureusement
n'ont pas non plus le plus conclure
d'accord avec les personnels navigants
commerciaux ont été jusqu'au bout de la
négociation nous avions un projet de
tête on s'est passé très très près mais
on a fait plus on n'a pas pu conclure
finalement mais j'aimerais tout à
l'heure nous avons visité catégories de
personnels après avoir je reconnais un
peu un peu hésité ne serait ce que par
respect pour les autres
réouvert des négociations depuis une
semaine je j'explique simplement je suis
peut-être attendez un instant sur ce
point là les personnes navigants
commerciaux chez nous ont une
caractéristique est différente des deux
autres catégories de personnel leur
accord l'accord qui régit les conditions
de travail et un accord à durée
déterminée il l'avait voulu en 2000
lorsqu'ils ont signé le précédent accord
en 2008
c'était un choix et donc leur accord
expire au 31 mars 2013
al'inverse du des pilotes et des
personnels au sol dont l'accord était un
dur et à l'accord à durée indéterminée
donc cet accord à durée déterminée il
n'était pas possible de le dénoncer a
pas d'accord à durée déterminée quand il
est possible également de dénoncer des
accords durée indéterminée
premier point et il exige
en l'absence de renégociation d'un
nouvel accord au 31 mars
nous pouvons imposer unilatéralement des
conditions de qui réglemente l'emploi de
nos personnels navigants commerciaux
donc ce que nous avons jugé nécessaire
c'était 2 après l'échec de négociations
c'était d'attendre un petit peu pour
regarder comment elle évolue et l'état
d'esprit le déploiement des accords déjà
signés nous sommes dit que comme nous
préférions un accord avec les personnes
à lyon commerciaux je pense que c'est
plutôt nécessaire pour vous demander des
efforts que les gens n'acceptent plus
qu'on leur impose nous avons décidé d
ouvrir ces négociations avec 4,4
principe c'est toujours 20% d'économies
ne serait-ce même que par souci d'équité
il aurait été difficile d'expliquer aux
autres que nous réouvriront après avoir
échoué après avoir offert les mêmes
délais les mêmes conditions des
négociations et que nous changions
l'objectif l'âge au delà je crois que si
on affrontait un animal d'ailleurs qu'on
n'aurait pas pu franchir
deuxième principe le calendrier est
respecté ses abdos 31 mars y a pas
d'accord on impose unilatéralement des
conditions pour atteindre ces 20%
troisièmement nous sommes repartis du
projet d'accord que nous avons failli
signer
et puis nous on va regarder s'il ya des
mesures qu'il faut que nous fassions
évolué voilà et puis la quatrième chose
importante qu'il faut que la commission
est bien à l'esprit c'est que en
présence d' accord et ça figurait dans
le projet d'accord il y aura des
contreparties pour les pnc des
contreparties en termes de par exemple
plan de départs volontaires garantie de
rémunération chose auquel nous étions
parvenus à un accord dans le projet ont
pu être signés intervention syndicale
mais sans accord il n'y a pas de
contrepartie faux faux faux
je crois qu'il ya une prime à la
signature je crois que c'est d'abord
pas par principe mais aussi par respect
pour les autres les autres finalement
ont signé des accords qui était qui
était d'équilibrer s'il sera difficile
là en l'absence de signature d'accords
d'accorder le même niveau de
contrepartie le même niveau de deux
mesures au pnc
donc voilà nous espérons conclure un
accord mais saison ni très très
favorable pour conclure faut être deux
j'espère que nos interlocuteurs enfin de
en l'espèce 4 parce qu'il ya au moins
trois devant trois occasions syndicales
représentatives il en faudrait 2 pour
que l'accord puisse être signé dans des
conditions qui soient acceptables au
titre des initiations sur la
représentativité doivent être syndicale
troisième point est troisième et dernier
volet je m'arrête là pardon d'avoir été
un peu longue président mais la
reconquête commerciale
donc pour nous pour être commerciale
elle passe par deux volets la lutte
contre les low cost les low cost nous
pose un défi
nous allons y répondre à la fois à
travers le pôle régional français la
partie air france et transavia notamment
parce que nous avons une offre qui
couvre bien tous les segments du marché
et parce que nous allons lancer des
offres commerciales à prix réduit avec
option je le donne je ne peux pas vous
en dire plus dans l'annoncé en janvier
ne voudront pas déflorer de ce sujet
mais on va essayer de s'adresser à cette
clientèle qui recherche des prix limitée
mais qui est prêt à payer des options
qui n'est pas prêt parce que pour pour
des raisons choix de principe de pouvoir
d'achat enfin qu'on peut qu'on peut
imaginer
donc une lutte déterminée contre les low
cost détermine ce n'est pas un peu plus
un jeu précise que la compagnie delta
notre allié que nous connaissons bien a
réussi dans son projet à limiter
l'évolution des locaux sur le territoire
américain il était vous avez confronté à
locaux sont plus anciennes sauvez taïwan
est normal qu il y avait la fameuse
south west qui a été le promoteur
initial historique un des low-cost
ok on a fait beaucoup de l'ouvragé sur
ce qu'il fallait faire pour faire une
coupe et il fallait faire south west
delta démontré qu'en étant delta il
arrivait à arrêter la progression de sa
ressource et même à reconquérir des
parts de marché donc cesser ce ce n'est
pas une une ambition je crois y réalise
d'autres pas sur l'ensemble du reste
notre gamme tous
le moyen-courrier d'apport sur le hub et
le long courrier c'est la remontée en
gamme du produit en france
nous pensons que lorsque nous penserons
portois la france de notre patronyme
donc nous pouvons jouer sur les atouts
de la france le le la qualité de la vie
et savoir vivre la cuisine le produit de
luxe
je pense que nous pouvons attirer
davantage de clients notamment des pays
émergents qui sont notre frontière en
long-courrier ici ce qu'il faut pour
nous c'est convaincre les brésiliens les
chinois les indiens de monter sur nos
avions je crois que cette clientèle est
très sensible à l'image de la france et
à la qualité de produit que la france
peut lui fournir
alors bien sûr à son négliger non plus
les classes seule la classe éco comme on
dit mais il sait puisque et puisque nous
les programmes que nous mettons en
oeuvre touche aussi la classe eco dans
l'amélioration du produit que et la
qualité de service que nous proposons
donc un très gros effort il avait
rappelé président ses 550 presse près de
600 millions maintenant de rénovation de
nos projets de nos deux noms long
courrier pour améliorer ce produit dans
tous les domaines les sièges la
nourriture la télévision à bord le
service au sol pour que je crois que
nous puissions être fiers collectivement
en tant qu' en tant que entend français
un delà de la compagnie nationale comme
étant une des première compagnie
mondiale en terme de qualité de service
notre objectif en 2016 est revenu dans
les premiers en termes de qualité de
service alors que sur certains sur
certains réseaux
nous sommes des classes et voilà quelle
est l'ambition de ce plan le président
messieurs nous ça me fait évidemment
disposé à répondre à toutes les
questions qu'on n'a pas pu aborder
jusqu'ici je vous remercie de votre
attention si monsieur président alors
donc la première question est posée par
monsieur vincent capo-canellas ce qui
rapporteur du budget et qui est maire du
bourget donc qui à ce titre là je pense
à des compétences tout à fait reconnu
merci monsieur le président je vais
essayer d'être digne de cet éloge
premier première question monsieur le
président de juniac vous avez abordé en
toute franchise la problématique
financière qui est la vôtre et avaient
été des chiffres qui montrent l'ampleur
des défis à relever j'ai d'abord envie
de vous dire ou es ce que vous en êtes
de l'application financière du plan
transforme 2015 que vous êtes dans les
clous et qu'en est il des échéances à
venir notamment sur la dette vous avez
évoqué des chiffres tout à l'heure je
crois qu'il ya des échéances courant
voilà est-ce que vous êtes dans la dans
la cible et est ce que tout ça suppose
que la compagnie arrivera à franchir le
cap sur sur ce premier point vous avez
affiché un objectif de retour à la
profitabilité
on dit souvent que les compagnies
américaines ont fortement augmenter leur
profitabilité
s'il ya un secret américain à regarder
et est ce que on peut s'inspirer de
cette pratique là parce qu'on voit bien
que c'est effectivement un point central
pour eux pour fo si vous avez rappelé
vous-même que ce secteur est malgré tout
marqué par un faible taux de
profitabilité en général deuxième
question sur le trafic parce que la clé
de la profitabilité c'est quand même
aussi bien sur la marche sur chaque fois
mais quelle est l'évolution du trafic
j'ai compris que sur le moyen et long
courrier ça ça se tenait plutôt pas trop
mal
qu'en est-il sur le trafic intérieur et
puis le trafic trafic européen
on avait un stand de crainte à la
rentrée est ce qu'il ya une
stabilisation
en tout cas dans dans vos comptes sur la
la question des peines est bon quand la
balle est dans le camp de la négociation
et merci d'avoir encore une fois abordé
en tout en toute clarté
est ce que quand vous aurez boucler ces
accords vous estimez que ce plan
telle qu'elle est viable ou est-ce que
compte tenu de la dégradation de la
conjoncture
qu'on peut toujours craindre il sera
nécessaire d'y revenir
la question ensuite sur la stratégie low
cost on connaissait la phrase qui est
communément admise et on a tendance à
dire
hong hong et le low cost on ne devient
pas vous êtes en train de nous dire
qu'il ya des exemples aux états unis il
encore qu'ils qui montre qu'on peut on
peut sans doute le devenir
je crois que les annonces sont à venir
puisque vous avez annoncé
on va attendre sans doute le mois de
janvier mais quels moyens pour
effectivement existé sur ce marché là je
crois qu'il ya un défi majeur pour pour
air france comment pensez vous y arrivez
et puis en fin d'année points vous avez
tout à l'heure et vaud qui rapidement et
il a demandé que soit le président je ne
sais plus où est ce que vous en êtes de
la stratégie d'alliances d'air france à
l'international et s'il ya du nouveau
sur sur ces sujets là merci à vous merci
monsieur michel teston oui merci cher
président le président de juniac
d'abord quelques remarques et questions
sur la situation actuelle et puis comme
vient de le faire ça je me projette très
aussi dans l'avenir et en particulier
par rapport au projet qui est peut-être
abandonné aux suspendus de monter au
capital d'alitalia
en ce qui concerne le plan de
transformer 2015
vous avez donc rappelé les accords
intervenus avec certaines catégories de
personnel essentiellement donc tout ce
qui est personnel
donc qui pilote et puis personnel au sol
et par contre la discussion reprend si
on nous a bien écouté avec les hôtesses
et les stewards qui sont régis par des
contrats de travail à durée déterminée
ce qui n'est pas le cas des autres
catégories de personnel donc macquet par
convention pas sur notre faim là le
l'accord
qui réglemente les conditions de travail
et à durée déterminée décontraction
décédé ce sont des cdi aussi oui ils
sont les amiral de donner vie à faire
des frais s'ils n'avaient pas compris
par d'anciens jusqu'à quand merci cela
commencera donc la question c'est si
vous n'arrivez pas à trouver un accord
avec eux vous n'avez pas pu en trouver
un récemment contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé avec les autres catégories
de personnel que va-t-il se passer est
ce que les grèves sont à craindre et
quelles sont les conséquences que cela
peut avoir
effectivement pour l'activité d'air
france
j'en viens maintenant à l'avenir on peut
supposer que avec les mesures qui ont
été prises vous allez retrouver
effectivement de la productivité
retrouver des marges et réussir on vous
le souhaite du moins à réduire notre
dette par rapport à a donc vos capitaux
mais dans ces conditions qu en est-il de
du projet qui consistait à monter au
capital d'alitalia
ça faisait partie des accords intervenus
à ma connaissance entre les deux
gouvernements français et italien dans
la douleur au début mai puis ensuite je
crois dans la concertation et également
entre les deux compagnies est ce que
c'est purement et simplement suspendus
ou bien est-ce que c'est purement et
simplement abandonnée qu'en est il il me
semble qu'il faut faire en sorte de
maillet au niveau européen une présence
d'air france avec les compagnies alliés
de manière à ce qu'on puisse comme le
fait par ailleurs lufthansa dans le
reste de l'europe pouvoir disposer
effectivement une grande compagnie
française qui puisse continuer à jouer
un rôle de premier plan au niveau hors
pair mais également au niveau mondial
merci monsieur alain fouché
mais monsieur le président de deux
petits points
vous avez évoqué
régional airlines me souviens vous étiez
nuit à quelques mois j'avais dû poser la
même question mais votre réponse avait
été un petit peu flou je crois donc vous
avez évoqué mais cette entreprise à
cette filiale qui comprend plusieurs
centaines de salariés à des salariés qui
sont inquiets il semblerait que mr frank
favorise plus ces syndicats de pilotes
qui sont très puissants il semblerait
aussi que vous récupérez un certain
nombre de lignes sont desservies par
régional airlines pour y envoyer les
avions d'air france
donc je veux dire quel est l'avenir de
regional airlines il ya quand même bien
centaines d'emplois qui sont concernés
que j'aimerais avoir c'est de votre part
une réponse claire parce que il ya une
inquiétude chez les salariés vous savez
comme moi que les pilotes sont des gens
qui souvent ce n'est pas vous apprendrez
qui se forme et qu'ils financent leur
formation que ça coûte très très cher
les noms pour les actes et puissent
empreinte pendant des années alors quel
est l'avenir de regional airlines
deuxième point moi j'habite le long de
l'atlantique enfin j'habite à poitiers
mondiaux à tous les marchés sont raflés
par ryanair nan c'est pas un peu tout le
beau coup de ma saison a fait alors je
veux dire ça blesse et zeller un petit
peu pour est ce que vous répondez à tous
les appels d'offres
comment se fait-il que vous l'ayez pas
de marché on sait qu adrian et et est
aidé par les chambres de commerce par
les villes etc
mais je veux dire régional airlines ou
air france peut être aidé aussi de la
même manière alors pourquoi et où pas de
marché mais pas répondu au moment où il
le fallait
c'est ce que vous êtes désintéresser de
cette clientèle là j'aimerais savoir
parce que c'est un peu dommage que notre
compagnie nationale de cette filiale ne
soit pas présente sur ces marchés qui
sont très important c'est les boîtiers
l'on souhaite retour longue c'est la
corse est partout merci monsieur jean
jacques filleul bien quand même su
président
groupe oui monsieur le président merci
je suis totalement d'accord avec la
question de mon collègue fichiers vous
que certaines certaines lignes d'une
reiner qui nous qui nous cassent un peu
les pieds il ya beaucoup d'argent public
l'allemand bien moi j'avais quelques
questions peut-être un peu marginale
parce que beaucoup de questions
intéressantes ont été posées par par nos
collègues nous parle d'aménagement du
territoire dans le cadre du plan de
redressement je n'ai pas entendu qu'air
france avait des vues de 2,2 de
modification de sa stratégie en
direction du rail
c'est ce qu'il y a une stratégie en
direction du rail puisque nous avons la
ligne lgv en particulier qui nous qui
nous importe en ce moment entre tours et
entre paris et bordeaux
on nous avait parlé à une époque d'une
possible concurrence tgv de deir france
voilà c'était une ouvrira en 2017
est ce qu'il y a est ce qu'il y à une
tentation de ce côté là en matière dames
et deux 2 et confortement mots d'albert
france sur le territoire national une
autre question totalement différentes
dans le monde il y à de très grandes
compagnies transport de fret
nous les connaissons elles sont
puissantes
est ce que pour une compagnie comme air
france le fret peut être une solution
pour continuer de contribuer à la
rentabilisation d'entreprise et à sa
consolidation
une troisième question qui
il m'est venue lorsque je vous ai
entendu parler d'eux et d'ailleurs à
juste titre des compagnies des pays
émergents du fait que ce sont des
compagnies privées mais aussi très
soutenus par leur part les états qui en
fait sont des compagnies qui quelque
part reflète la puissance de tel ou tel
nouveaux états émergents
est-ce que esquire france klm
aujourd'hui a besoin de plus d'état dans
sa stratégie et table
oui d'europe et des détails je le dis
parce que c'est une compagnie privée et
je me posais cette question vous
entendant vous l'avez pas vous avez pas
émis ce propos avec gourmandise je vois
bien mais en même temps on l'avait
soulevée et donc je me permets de dire
venir dernière question quelle est la
part des constructeurs d'avions dans la
flotte d'air france merci je président
simon voulait bien répondre dans cette
première série tout d'abord où on est où
en est sur le plan financier le plan
transforme alors le plan transforme soit
le plan financier pour 2012 devraient
nous amener et c'est ce que nous avons
donné que des hommes comme perspective à
la communauté financière comme vous
savez là dessus c'est une chose
extrêmement surveillée ces deux d'avoir
des résultats qu'ils soient meilleurs en
2012 qu'en 2011 et une première baisse
de la dette sachant que notre
perspective à l'horizon 2 fin 2014 c'est
d'avoir baissé la dette de deux
milliards d'euros
donc ramener la dette de 6 milliards à 4
milliards et 6 milliard et demi par mois
1 4 milliard et demi être revenu à la
profitabilité dès 2014
mais avec une profitabilité
significative
c'est à dire entre 6 et 8% prouver ça
signifie ça reste quand même faible mais
pour les autres pour les compagnies
aériennes c'est bien
en 2015 c'est de la perspective que nous
avons pour l'instant nous sommes sur le
chemin mais nous sommes sur le chemin
juste dit autrement
nous n'avons pas le choix que de faire
l'intégralité du plan transform ya pas
de n'y a pas de marge de manoeuvre
sachant que le plan a été bâtie sur des
poésies potet économique plutôt
prudentes prudente en matière de
croissance de trafic est très prudente
en matière de croissance des capacités
que nous mettons à disposition des
passagers pour vous donner à une
référence
nous avions l'habitude de croître à un
taux de 1 tôt d'autres cas compris entre
4 et 5% pour nos capacités mettez entre
4 et 5 % de capacité le plus sur le
marché jusqu'en 2011
nous allons remettre entre 1 et 2 plutôt
plus près de 1 que de 2 sur les trois
prochaines années donc les hypothèses
ont été prudents je vous avais
incidemment parler de la profitabilité
des compagnies américaines
comment font-elles à la il ya une chose
qui est bien c'est le chapitre 11
le chapitre 11 permet auprès des mairies
ken non seulement de renégocier
totalement clos créanciers et non et
d'abaisser pour beaucoup leur créance
souvent transformé en capitale
ce cadre delta les principales banques
créancières son double actionnaires et
deuxièmement de renégocier l'intégralité
des accords avec les personnels sous le
contrôle du juge
voilà c'est ce qui est en train de faire
american airlines est actuellement donc
c'est évidemment c'est en fait ils
transforment leur modèle économique
complètement en faisant ça c'est pas
transposable en france voilà enfin pas
tel quel alors l'évolution du trafic que
que nous que nous constatons le trafic
subi une évolution contrastée
il reste très correcte dans l'ensemble
des catégories que ce soit loisirs ou à
faire sur le long courrier
il ya une pression squatter nos taux de
remplissage sont bons sur le moyen
courrier et de courts courriers l'europe
du nord se tient l'alimentation du hub
se tient mais l'europe du sud subit un
très net ralentissement presqu'un
presqu'une presque un effondrement
l'italie et l'espagne surprendra
personne je pense tous à table et la
france ralentit très très très nettement
le trafic domestique france est très
très ralentie notamment dans la partie à
faire par rapport à la partie de loisirs
la partie loisirs se tiendrait plutôt
mieux que la partie à faire ce qui
témoigne soit pour que les français
continuent à voyager pour l'or pour leur
prouver leur propre plaisir mais aussi
du fait que les politiques voyages ont
progressivement basculer des passagers
de la classe avant affaire va la classe
arrière loisirs voir que les entreprises
voyage moi donc il ya ya ya un ensemble
cet ensemble et nous inquiète beaucoup
moins nous suivons ça mois par mois se
fassent eux-mêmes par semaine même jour
par jour et donc le trafic européen
notamment d'europe du sud est très
faible
heureusement que l'europe du nord tient
encore éclater à continental se
maintient voilà pour vous donner des
émotions trafic nos taux de remplissage
pour l'instant reste correct crois qu
air france air france klm bénéficient de
l'équipe dit programme et du revenue
management qui est probablement une des
meilleurs duos et celle qui gère la
recette et l'attribution des avions sur
des bonnes lignes et la constitution
d'un programme de vols est vraiment une
des meilleures sur le marché donc c'est
ce qui explique on arrive dans des
pistes conjoncture qui est très
difficile à maintenir une
une une activité qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas trop trop catastrophique est ce que
le plan est viable est ce qu'il faut on
transforme deux jeunes gens tant
d'autres questions comme ça je voudrais
dire deux choses là dessus la première
c'est que nous avons bâti transforme sur
3 en 2012 2014 avec une clause de rendez
vous officiellement signé les actions
syndicales au deuxième semestre 2013
puisque comme vous l'avez rappelé
président nous avons malheureusement dû
procéder à 5122 suppressions d'emplois
unique qui qui qui se font dans les
conséquences ne sont que que si je puis
dire des départs volontaires il n'y a
aucun il n'y a aucun départ contraint
comme vous le savez mais c'est 5122
suppressions d'emplois elles sont
valables en 2012 et 2013
il y aura il y aura peut-être une
tranche 2014 nous ne savons pas encore
il ya une clause de rendez-vous pour ça
pour déterminer s'il ya lieu qu'il y ait
une tranche 2014 et si oui comment ce
qu'on doit l'évaluer donc dans le plan
transforme nous avons déjà prévu qu'il
pouvait si la conjoncture se dégrade
excessivement 6,6 de nos performances
n'étaient pas au rendez vous y avoir une
clause de rendez-vous qui nous amène à
prévoir un à un un volet en 2014
vous avez évoqué la question mais à mon
sens pour l'instant et en l'absence de
catastrophe économique et compte tenu de
la prudence de nos hypothèses il n'y a
pas besoin de faire implantant un
d'autres d'autres mesures de
restructuration industrielle dans les
plans transforme il rappelait quelque
chose à faire en matière en matière de
réduction de coûts et d'emploi pour nous
mais c'est trop tôt pour le dire
beaucoup trop tôt vous avez évoqué le
point des low cost on naît low cost on
n'est pas low cost est ce qu'on va
devenir low cost dans la question n'est
pas ça pardon je suis sans doute et je
pense que c'était clair on va pas
transformer leurs horaires font sur low
cost c'est pas la peine s'est perdue ça
s'est perdu à deux titres je vous dis
nous sommes nous ne sommes pas low cost
nos coûts ne sont pas l'eau et puis
deuxièmement ça ne nous ne proposons pas
un produit sous la marque air france qui
soit un produit low cost et ce serait
une erreur de le faire parce que ça
attirerait la mare vers le bas
pour vous dire des choses vues vue sur
un plan marketing
le marché du court et du moyen-courrier
suivrait pour le long mais c'est très
très très bas pour le coin croyez est
divisé en trois segments
vous avez un segment qui fait 30% du
marché qui essayeront des gens prêts à
payer près soit parce qu'ils ont des
moyens soit parce que les entreprises
payent pour eux important marché c'est
un secteur qui a tendance à peut
abaisser le mans période de crise et à
ceux transférés dans les secteurs plus
bas les deux autres secteurs qui sont en
dessous de celui là c'est au plus bas
souvent des gens qui ne veulent pas
payer considère que le transport aérien
il faut payer le moins cher possible
donc ils font jouer des comparateurs de
prix sur internet
il pourrait tout les low cost et ça
c'est le séduire c'est la clientèle du
low cost de type ryanair pour reprendre
je souhaite à notre françois référence 1
c'est vraiment la prestation minimum
minimorum l'as tu crois pas qu'on puisse
se battre vraiment beaucoup
et puis il ya 40% du marché au milieu
s'ils ont des gens qui fluctuent pour
des raisons financières mais dont on
sent qu'ils sont très souvent très
content de voyager sur nous si vous
voulez mais que quand ils peuvent pas
mais beige et iv à choyer low costs à
cette clientèle là il faut absolument
qu'on a qu'on l'a sécurisé c'est l'objet
et c'est l'objet de notre politique
commerciale alors comment ce qu'on y
répond on à transavia qui est née low
cost ll est low cost elle reste l'os
voilà donc elle ne s'adresse au segment
low cost vous avez le p r f qui n'est
pas née low cost mais que qu'est le pôle
régional français pardon qui lui va va
faire une offre quand même avec des prix
réduits avec option je pense que c'est
bien c'est bien parce que c'est
il est confronté aux low cost pour je
crois monsieur le sénateur vous avez dit
que vous étiez rendant le dans l'ouest
vous avez eu sans doute à poitiers mais
enfin si vous voulez j'ai peut-être de
nantes 2 il ya une nouvelle low cost qui
vient de s'implanter en ouvrant en basin
3 a duré nantes compte qu'il existait
pas yann on s'appelle volontaire je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué vous voulez
pouvoir vous avez easyjet ryanair
vueling qui sont extrêmement et c'est
extrêmement
active et donc le port régional français
est aussi en concurrence avec les low
cost ya aussi des low cost ceux qui
m'aiment beaucoup qui partent des villes
de province des rabatteurs et pluie a
par ailleurs air france le réseau et air
france pour lequel lui s'adresse plutôt
à la clientèle des 30% duo et une partie
des 40 % du milieu mais nous allons
quand même proposer une offre un peu
adaptés aux gens qui veulent payer un
peu moins
vous verrez ça 7 janvier aux rays sur
les sur les murs de france quelques
affiches quelques politiques
commerciales pour proposer une nouvelle
offre sous très content dans quelques
mois si vous me faites l'honneur devrait
inviter va de commenter j'espère le
succès ça fait partie de notre conquête
les enfin dernière question vous est
posée je me suis atteint les alliances
air france dans ses alliances donc et
dans l'alliance skyteam comme je te dit
tout à l'heure nous avons pensé qu'il
était nécessaire ou sale air france klm
d'avoir une lotion avec une des
compagnies du golfe que ta pâte à
coopérer qu'etihad etihad et donc la
plus petite des trois emirates qatar et
y puise des trois très dynamique elle
est prête à coopérer parce qu'elles
pensent avec raison qu'elle ne
rattrapera pas son grand frère d'à côté
qui est à venir est le droit que je
crois que c'est raisonnable de le dire
est que pour eux la manière de rattraper
cette coopérer avec avec des grandes
donc c'est pour ça que nous avons signé
un accord pour l'instant de codeshare
entre abou dhabi d'une part ce qui paul
et charles de gaulle d'autre part où
nous partageons des vols et des bilans
je crois que c'est sage
non alors justement c'était très lourd
noter un peu précurseur dans ce domaine
puisque aucune des compagnies du golfe
il avait rejoint à une alliance
emirates pour l'instant ne veut pas
d'alliance ils ont fait une erreur ce
avec quoi tu as mais sans se mettre dans
l'alliance oneworld
peut-être que il estime devoir
constituer autour d'eux une attirance ne
sais pas je ne sais pas pour l'instant
les autres ont refusé et qatar a rejoint
oneworld donc progressivement à des
compagnies du golfe rejoindre les
alliances quand vous regardez
géographiquement le réseau c'est pas
idiot parce que vous verrez que sur
l'ensemble du réseau sous l'ensemble de
l'océan indien au sens large
c'est-à-dire afrique de l'est
1-2 pakistan bangladesh sri lanka jusque
jusqu'en australie ce qui représente un
milliard et demi de passagers potentiels
ainsi si c'est pas c'est pas un désert
la position des compagnies du doigté
très très forte et donc et nous avons
une position assez faible en réalité et
toutes les compagnies occidentales l'ont
des compagnies ont des positions assez
faible et donc c'est un très bon
complément monde pour ramener du trafic
si mauvais sur nos sur nos sous nos
réseaux je souhaite vous avez évoqué les
pnc
que se passe-t-il si après la cloche pas
si tu veux commenter ce point que nous
avons partagé avec les organisations
syndicales c'est que ce que disait le
président nous souhaitons donner une
prime à la signature d'accords parce que
le la politique contractuelle petit de
signature d'accords fait partie de
jaillir de la stratégie mais c'est
presque sa der france et que si nous
voulons que les organisations signent il
faut caser des bonnes raisons de le
faire les bonnes raisons c'est
évidemment les contreparties qu'elles
peuvent obtenir en signant alors de ce
point de vue là quelles sont les
contreparties qu'on a intégré dans les
accords que nous avons avec les deux
autres catégories qui sont les pilotes
et le personnel au sol essentiellement
d'eux la première qui est évidemment la
plus importante c'est que
nous sommes engagés à ne pas procéder à
des départs forcés et contraints de
l'entreprise d'ici la fin de 2014
c'est quand même un engagement tout à
fait tout à fait louable important que
nous avons pris et il ya également un
deuxième un deuxième engagement qui est
un engagement qui porte sur le fait que
dans le cas où la france reviendrait à
meilleure fortune donc là les comptes
d'air france s'améliorer plus rapidement
et plus fortement que qui n'est prévue
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes engagés en
fable et unifier les faire bénéficier de
cette amélioration les catégories
concernées concernés avec un style de
deux mesures un peu précis sur par
exemple une émission qui d'action qui
serait réservée aux salariés ou des
dispositifs de d'intéressement de
participation qui serait qui serait
qu'on dit un peu un peu musclé et de
trois de troisième chose aussi qui
paraît plus technique et comme
importante c'est que nous avons pris des
engagements de transparence la plus
complète avec les organisations qui ont
signé très concrètement ces
organisations ont désigné chacun en fin
de chaque cadre chaque catégorie donc le
sol et les pilotes ont désigné en fait
un expert et cet expert et et travaille
avec le petit groupe qui pilote
l'ensemble du projet transforme au sein
d'air france pour vite bien validé le
degré d'avancement les problèmes que
nous pouvons avoir les solutions à y
apporter et nous voyons dans les
organisations
une fois tous les deux mois pour faire
un bilan complet donc qu'ils ont la
transparence la plus complète sur ce qui
se passe dans l'entreprise
voilà donc ce que j'ai dit aux pnc c'est
que soit ce que nous avons dit aux
organisations syndicales qui
représentent donc les hôtesses et
stewards c'est que si on arrive à un
accord est évident que
les organisations pourront nous demander
des contreparties équivalente
s'il n'y arrivons pas maintenant cessé
contrepartie ne seront pas à présenter
donc on devra notamment prendre position
sur la question de savoir comment on
traite le problème d'emploi que nous
avons avec les pnc et qui a été chiffrée
de l'ordre de 500 à 600 emplois qui se
retrouvent durablement en sureffectif en
l'absence de données de mesure c'est là
où nous en sommes j'ai bien sûr elle est
à dire que ça te faisait poser la
question pour l'instant et je crois
qu'on peut parler davantage de
suspension que d'abandon il ya le nous
n'avons pas les moyens de monter au
capital d'alitalia ne pas les moyens de
faire beaucoup de chose d'ailleurs pour
ne rien vous cacher ccc la couronne pas
gagné beaucoup d'argent c'est même d'en
perdre et donc notamment de ne pas
pouvoir procéder à une opération qui
effectivement est intéressante pour
couvrir le sud de l'europe voilà ceci
dit pour pau il ya je crois qu'il ya
deux éléments qu'il faut que la
commission ait à l'esprit
premièrement la coopération est
exemplaire avec alitalia exemplaires que
ce soit dans l'alimentation de dos de
nos hommes notamment de nos lignes nord
et sud américaine des passagers italiens
grâce à l'italien la coopération
industrielle et très bonne nous on la
maintenance de leur avion est porté dans
un avion la coopération bi tah de
catherine c'est à dire de 2,2 de
nourriture à bord et voilà donc le et ça
se passe bien chaud la seconde chose
c'est que le les principaux acteurs
d'aller chez alitalia principaux
actionnaires et équipe dirigeante nous
sont plutôt favorables même pu sont
plutôt très favorable à une alliance
avec air france klm pour qu'on ne voit
pas toujours se tromper mais l'on ne
voit pas de rupture dans cette relation
même si nous sommes pour l'instant n'ont
pas les moyens de la deûle à conforter
financièrement
l'avenir de régionale alors régional
fait partie du pauvre jeune français
avec deux autres compagnies qui sont
brit air et et airlinair ils sont c'est
un très beau projet le pôle un jeune
français qui est fondée sur deux sur
deux éléments le premier élément c'est
pour air france l'alimentation de ses
hubs de
roissy et d'orly 40% du trafic en
affrètement c'est à dire que nous
affrétons leur avion pour alimenter en
passager nos robes premiers points 2e 2
et 4% du trafic
60 % de trafic c'est leur responsabilité
que le développer des lignes
transversales et nous air france nous
leur donnons l'appui stratégique et
commercial pour le faire et ce sont nos
équipes commerciales pas seulement
cirque ils passeront aussi par internet
tout ça de l'iseran mêmes et nos équipes
commerciales qui leur transfert des
clients par exemple les grands contre
affirment que nous avons que les grandes
entreprises françaises sur leur servent
en client le pôle régional français pour
des personnes qui voudraient faire du
nantes quelque chose parce qu'ils les
appartiennent par exemple alstom ou à
auch chantiers de l'atlantique c'est ce
genre de ce genre de d'appui que que de
leur condition donc régionales a
clairement un avenir pourrait bien le
français
c'est vrai que la situation sociale je
pense que vous l'évoquez aussi est plus
difficile des régionales qu'on avait des
autres compagnies publiques abritèrent
pourtant se décomposer assez comparable
en terme de taille l'un est plus
difficile qu'ailleurs lunaire c'est
comment dirais-je c'est un peu
historique régionale c'est à peu
construit contre air france
l'arn identité régionale s'est faite
contre la maison-mère pas le seul
endroit où ça arrive je crois et puis il
ya une vraie césure scission au sein des
organisations syndicales entre les
organisations de régional et celle d'air
france ce qui ne simplifie pas la vie
voilà enfin en tout cas d'un autre jeu
sur un point particulier que vous avez
évoqué monsieur le sénateur sur la
tendance que nous aurions à favoriser
nos propres syndicats par rapport aux
autres alors le débat en fait et est
venue de la question de savoir à qui
nous réservions les postes qui vont être
créées par le fait que la filiale low
cost du groupe transavia se développe
donc il est prévu que transavia passe de
8 à 14 avions
ce qui fait de l'ordre de 120 postes en
fait de deux pilotes à pourvoir et donc
il ya un débat pour savoir comment est
ce que nous allions pourvoir ces postes
alors il est vrai que au printemps comme
on a avancé plus vite avec le syndicat
des pilotes d'air france qu'avec les
autres syndicats de pilotes des autres
compagnies et bien le ce ce débat a
mûrit plus vite avec le syndicat des
pilotes d'air france nous avons
effectivement dit qu'une part nous
sommes engagés exactement est ce qu'une
part des des créations de poste soit
réservé aux pilotes d'air france ont en
tout cas soit proposé aux pilotes d'air
france
ensuite et ses pilotes décideront s'il
souhaite pourvoir le poste ou pas cela
dit le débat a mûri depuis et nous
sommes engagés l'encore à généraliser si
vous ne la démarche et donc à créer une
sorte de filières qui permettra aux
pilotes de régionales où tout
permettrait en cas de signature aux
pilotes de régional et du pôle régional
français en général également de prendre
des postes chez transavia est également
sous certaines hypothèses devenir
pourvoir des postes créés à la maison
mère chez air france donc dans le cas où
nous reprendrions une
la croissance que nous souhaitons tous
et nous reprendrions donc d embauche
donc le jeu reconnaît volontiers que le
débat en dire c'est organiser un peu au
fil des négociations et donc de l'avancé
des uns et des autres des noms avancés
des uns des autres mais il me semble que
nous avons bien mûri sur cette cette
question là et quand je dis nous c'est
évidemment la direction générale du
groupe mais également les différentes
organisations de pilote et moi je dis
que on est tout à fait prêt à pousser
désireux même de à poursuivre les
discussions pour essayer d'aboutir sur 7
sur cette question vous évoquez un sujet
d'atr les les low cost et notamment
ryanair et le les marchés que hockey
auquel renner s'adressent alors ryanair
il ya je crois deux catégories de low
cost et nous ne sommes pas en
concurrence avec toutes les catégories
de low cost il faut être
il faut être raisonnable nous il ya des
catégories de low cost qui vraiment s
adressent à la partie la plus basse du
marché avec des prix les plus bas mais
alors aussi aucune prestation
c'est quelqu'un à prix ryanair ici on
n'est pas très toujours très très bien
prêté donc cessé mais mais il ya un
marché pour ça et je respecte ce qu il
parte d'aéroport souvent qu'ils sont
plutôt secondaire par appareil papa de
pahé ni de charles de gaulle ni d'orly
parle de brevets dont ces low cost qui
effectivement ont dû positions
importantes en europe
elle s'adresse à une catégorie de marché
qui n'est pas la nôtre et sur lequel je
pense que nous ne pouvons pas porter une
concurrence très efficace ce que nous
pouvons faire c'est que les conditions
de concurrence dans lequel opèrent ces
compagnies soit équitable pour nous et
nous le faisons vis-à-vis de ryanair
notamment s'il ya des subventions
excessives ou des subventions qui nous
paraissent injustifiée c'est s'il ya des
conditions sociales et nous l'avons fait
vis à vis de certains de nos postes
d'emploi des personnels keane qui ne
nous paraissent pas adaptés nous avons
une décision juridictionnelle assez
favorable dans ce domaine là pour éviter
que les personnels au pair avec des
statuts disons entre guillemets
socialement dévalorisé sur le territoire
français ce qui arrive donc ça c'est
ce sont des actions que nous que nous
que nous poursuivons mais il faut bien
dire que renner s'adresse à une
catégorie de marchés
cliquez qui est qui et qui est difficile
pour nous en revanche une autre
catégorie low cost qui s'adresse à un
marché le plus élevé c'est easyjet que
vous connaissez je n'aime pas citer non
mes concurrents ma femme qui l'a viens
viens d'ailleurs marcher sur les
plates-bandes d'air france s'adressant
sa clientèle a fait commence à connaître
der des sujets que nous connaissons tous
les jours par exemple quand vous faites
un embarquement avec des places
attribuées ce que ne faisait pas hésité
est ce que maintenant il est amené à
faire
il est très très difficile de tenir les
30 minutes de turner en taille de
l'avion ce qu'on appelle arrivée
débarquement rembarquement en 30 minutes
c'est plus difficile voilà donc qui sont
en train progressivement de connaître
aussi les contraintes la de la compagnie
historique mais là ce sont nos vrais
concurrents
je fais observer qu'ils opèrent à partir
des héros principaux 1 la base easyjet
est juste devant mon bureau à charles de
gaulle je peux dire ça c'est au cas où
j'aurais été un tout petit petit moment
de déprime ça me remonte le moral voilà
pendant ces 16 elle est aussi elle opère
comme vous savez aussi à partir d'orly
donc là c'est une là c'est une vraie
concurrence et c'est à cette concurrence
là que notre politique enfin que notre
nouvelle politique commerciale et
industrielle s'adressent davantage car
ryanair ou là on aura vraiment du mal à
opérer sous les mêmes conditions que le
cored
vous avez évoqué mais le sénateur la la
la stratégie rails
la stratégie iphone pour nous ce
résultat binaire suivant quand le tgv
arrive le trafic historique entre la
ville desservie par le tgv et paris
s'effondre quand je dis s'effondre c'est
que s'est divisée par deux en quelques
mois donc c'est assez c6 est imbattable
effondrement donc nous ne voyons pas
d'un bon oeil
nous comprenons par ailleurs et le tgv
apporte des plus étonnants la seule
chose que nous faisons observer on sait
une chose je parle souvent avec
guillaume pépy donc s'il n'y a pas de
polémique là dedans c'est que les
infrastructures pour nous sont financés
par nos alors que les infrastructures
pour le train n'est pas totalement
financé par le passage et c'est tout ce
que
là-dessus la concurrence intermodal vue
de nous des pas totalement équitable si
si si s'il fallait
s'il fallait évoquer comme ça mais mais
non mais testons nommé je l'admets très
bien s'aimer c'est ce qui explique ce
qui explique que lorsque le tgv arrive
notre notre part de marché s'effondre
c'est ce qui vient d'arriver très très
malheureusement je ne discute avec cent
d'entre vous à strasbourg c'était
c'était très très dur mais
l'effondrement du trafic était totale
c'est ce qui nous est arrivé sur lyon à
l'époque c'était notre principale ligne
à lyon parions principales lignes des
radicaux vie n'existe plus pour nous non
c'est pas vrai toulouse et va le risque
de bordeaux se profile se profiler ya
aucun doute
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons là la
partie de la réponse que nous apportons
à nos passagers principalement c'est de
faire un accord la sncf ils sont
d'accord et sncf pour pour que les
horaires et les modes de transport
puisse puisse se combiner club dire
qu'on puisse amener des passagers en
train notre hub de charles de gaulle ça
m'amène pardon un point que je ne peux
pas m'en que je peux pas m'empêcher
alors de 2,2 de mentionner de votre
commission c'est l'accessibilité nos
deux parisiens est très mauvaise
qu'elles soient en train en transport
public parisien ou par la route
c'est julien le dire désastreuse cc
c'est indigne d'un pays du niveau de la
france quand on se contente on se
promène en europe et dans le monde
bonjour
et enfin je la sais ta prohm d'intérêt
général nous avons des infrastructures
d'intérêt national que sont charles de
gaulle et orly d'intérêt national dont
la desserte avec la capitale ou même
avec le reste de la france
et à mon avis comme le principal client
des reports de paris très très très
insuffisante très insuffisante
voilà alors je me permets de dire c'est
aussi voilà pour certains c'est un boss
était absolument exacte mais un certain
air en sorte de croyance qu'ils ont
plutôt mieux fait si vous ou moi je
pense à lyon lyon a mis très brillant je
le jure je pense que nous les français
nous verrions absolument mais pour
charles de gaulle quand même une
plateforme internationale international
ça va être probablement le premier hub
d'europe puisque c'est la seule qu'elle
claquait la capacité vraiment
additionnel je vois je tiens à dire que
là nous avons un retard qui est ce que
je considère comme un grand paris à
m'améliorer
il ya plusieurs choses mais plusieurs
choses dia cdg express le grand paris la
desserte routière quand même je pense
que pour ceux qui vous critiquent
commune à roissy deux à trois fois par
jour ce qui est notre cas autour de
cette table vous dire que il ya un petit
peu de travail sur la desserte routière
si je puis me permettre
mais monsieur capoue connaissent le sait
très bien aussi voilà et c'est vrai pour
orly sur ce qui est important pour
l'aménagement du territoire puisque
c'est à orly qu'est notre plateforme
nationale
donc voilà je fasse je me permets de
deux de ces baptêmes et vous le savez
parfaitement vous avez posé question du
fret le sénateur le fret
c'est vrai que jeune je n'ai pas insisté
sur le fret le fret est dans une
situation qui est qui n'est pas
difficile mais très difficile elle est
très difficile parce que non seulement
le commerce mondial a ralenti donc le
flux le flux trafic a ralenti mais en
plus on est en surcapacité absolument
chronique en matière de transport de
fret
et cette surcapacité est dû à deux
choses elle est due à l'arrivée d'un sam
compagnie compagnies du golfe compagnies
chinoises notamment d'avions cargo qui
avait été commandé en 2008 2009 qui
arrive un service et d'ailleurs qui sont
immédiatement mis au sol ce que les
compagnies du golfe qui ont des
capacités contre tous car vos mises au
sol des bidons jusqu'à ne servent pas
mais on imagine bien que des salles à
repartir les
avions vont arriver sur le marché pour
ça que tirent les prix vers le bas
bon il y à un deuxième élément que la
commission doit avoir l'esprit c'est que
la taille des allures augmenté 1 et
notamment la capacité soute à augmenter
la capacité sous de la triple sept
d'abord inc 77 et le double à peu près
de la capacité de 747 donc nous soude
qui somme qui est qui et qui sont aussi
un élément important du cargo et des
sweats de tous les opérateurs a beaucoup
augmenté et vient augmenter
considérablement la capacité mis sur le
marché
donc on a un marché déprimé en termes de
demande et surcapacitaires en matière
d'offre donc c'est une c'est un
véritable désastre industriel et je
remarque nous ne sommes pas les seuls
qatar qui possède une part dans cargolux
cargolux étant là l'entreprise le cargo
luxembourgeoise assez assez dynamique
s'est retiré dans des conditions très
difficiles les allemands ont arrêté leur
joint-venture les chinois en matière le
cargo les flux à destination mais
surtout en provenance de la chine se
sont effondrés pseudo hong kong shanghai
et plus se sont effondrés et le
transport maritime a fait beaucoup de
progrès que ce soit en terme de
logistique de taille de la vire ou même
au même jeu si cet exemple est
intéressant de capacité d'emport de
produits frais par exemple sur on ne
pouvait pas porter de fleurs auparavant
sur les sol et par transport maritime
sur les fleurs fanées ce qui va de soi
donc donc donc ça venait dans le foot
mais on arrive maintenant à endormir
certaines fleurs et donc allez allez
allez transportés par voie maritime sur
tes sens qu'elle arrive à mi mai ben oui
c'est intéressant mais voilà ce soir
deux choses qui peuvent explique donc le
fret pour extrêmement difficile et il
fait partie est un des éléments
malheureusement les plus douloureux de
la restructuration que nous avons amené
des deux côtés klm est un opérateur de
frêt plus important la hollande est un
passeur vols logistiques de l'europe
qu'air france les complets alors faut-il
plus d'état compte tenu de la l'arrivée
de nouvelles compagnies
je ne sais pas si c'est plus ou moins
d'état l'état pour nous nous avons coupé
des donc je n'ai pas de il nous a
beaucoup soutenus à dans la démarche
plan transforme donc avec jeu-là dire
beaucoup de à la fois beaucoup
discipline de retenue de deux supports
donc vraiment ça s'est passé dans des
conditions tout à fait exemplaire
je vous crois que l'intervention de
l'état dans air france france klm serait
maintenant quasiment impossible pour des
raisons européenne comme vous le savez
je crois qu'on sera immédiatement
qualifiée d'états une part et d'autre
part il faut pas oublier que nous sommes
air france klm
ça n'est pas totalement de nous ne
sommes plus totalement france nous
sommes aussi une compagnie nationale
hollande qui est un des fleurons
nationaux ainsi vous avez mentionné que
la france est un fleuron de notre pays
calais est un fleuron et c'est
fondamental cette alliance elle est
fondamentale ah oui oui si ce qu'elle
aime c'est air france est fini mais en
forçant klm s'est certes pas bien parce
que c'était une compagnie qui a eu un
immense développement international qui
est lié sous les assauts à ce caractère
très international ce pays
non seulement en termes de logistique
ainsi la place en russie de l'europe
quand on visite rotterdam
c'était un régime que tout le monde a pu
a pu le constater mais qui avait un
réseau passagers incroyable pour un pays
de 11 millions 13 millions d'habitants
et donc le complément du réseau
international qu'elle est même celui
d'air france est une force formidable
donc je sais c'est une donc je crois que
le l'état joue son rôle où nous nous ce
que nous ce que nous faisons ce que nous
pensons important dans lorsque l'état
doit faire ses effets des conditions de
concurrence européennes et
internationales soient bien respectées
c'est ce qu'on a expliqué tola vis-à-vis
des low cost mais ça vaut aussi pour les
droits de trafic accordés à des
compagnies tierces non européennes pour
lequel je crois qu'il faut être prudent
tous droits de trafic que vous accordez
une compagnie non européenne qui
bénéficie des avantages des compagnies
ils ont à l'est de l'europe c'est de
l'emploi qui part il faut le savoir
et et pardon il y avait le président y
avait la part des constructeurs dans la
flotte alors la part des constructeurs
nous avons une répartition assez
équilibré à airbus boeing ce qui est
raisonnable pour une compagnie comme
nous quand il ya deux grands
fournisseurs il serait imprudent d'avoir
tous nos tous nos tous nos avions chez
le même constructeur
donc pour air france en global on et 75%
airbus 25% boeing sachant qu'on long
courrier on est 35 % airbus 63 100 % bio
est en réalité tout notre photo moyen
court et moyen courrier et airbus et
notre flotte long-courrier et deux tirs
boeing un tiers intérieur bus pour
l'accompagner reportage parle d'air
france je parle pas des filiales
régionales ou là nous avons dû
bombardier duhaime braire parce que
c'était dû à de la tr mais pas puisque
les constructeurs ne sont pas les mêmes
klm était une compagnie qui était quasi
exclusivement boeing quelques
d'exploiter deux a330
la nouvelle commande d'a350 et 2 et 2
587 que nous avons passés en 2011 klm va
commencer à exploiter également les 350
merci trois dernières questions monsieur
gérard cornu oui monsieur le président
vous nous avez expliqué très clairement
la problématique financière d'air france
avec son sonde et man est important
finalement air france est un colosse aux
pieds d'argile
et s'il a le colosse glissé sur le pied
d'argile sur l'argile qu'est-ce qui se
passerait est-ce que air france n'est
pas à l'abri d'une et en plus vous avez
dit que que les compagnies européennes
étaient en difficulté alors que le
compagnie internationale autre que
européenne était assez bien portante
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si il y avait
une compagnie ou deux compagnies
chinoises dans lequel sont qui
appartient à skyteam par exemple
voudrais faire une opa sur air france
klm est ce que
est ce que c'est un risque voilà qu'est
ce qui se passerait quoi donc ça c'est
quand même bon je vais être provocateur
mais c'est sait jamais je voudrais je
voudrais revenir sur d'autres questions
la lutte effectivement contre les locaux
chez vous il y avait répondu globalement
il me semble mais je voudrais avoir une
petite précision
mais comme les locaux c'est bien pointe
à points est donc votre liste votre
lutte va être à travers votre avec havas
à travers 30 à vire est-ce que ça passe
aussi par par des ce lot des transferts
de ce lot d'air france 2 du pôle air
france vers le pôle transavia pour
essayer de lutter sur sur d autres
compagnies low cost vous n'a pas du tout
parlé alors que c'est finalement le
point le plus essentiel à mon avis c'est
de toutes les compagnies aériennes
c'est le taux de remplissage de vue je
voudrais savoir si une évolution là
dessus si si voilà vous avez en ce qui
concerne donc roissy orly on va revenir
plus parisien plus ce france donc on a
bien compris que roy si c'était votre
bain etc
concernant orly vous avez la navette
liaisons courtes distances et puis les
dom tom
est ce que mes orly roissy l'intérêt
c'est que il ya un hacker au sud de la
france et l'auto nord de la france et
c'est vrai que quand vous habitez sur
l'ouest ou le sud de la france cède
parfois plus facile d'aller orly que
d'aller à roissy parce qu'il faut se
faire tout le tout le trajet est ce que
il est envisageable de gagner encore des
ce lot à à orly pour faire en sorte
faciliter les passerelles faciliter la
venue des passagers sur sur orly et de
pouvoir prendre à la fois
transavia ou air france
merci evelyne didier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président merci
pour votre la clarté vous vous exposez à
la clarté de vos réponses
j'avais plusieurs questions mais vous
avez déjà répondu à certaines je voulais
notamment vous interroger sur le fret
que vous n'aviez pas évoqué mais nous
avons eu les éléments tout de suite ma
première question est celle ci film que
représente la masse salariale sur lens
sur votre budget en pourcentage
ma deuxième question c'est sa portée et
vous avez déjà commencé à répondre sur
avec le faire concurrence aux
complémentarités
mais bon vous avez déjà donné des
éléments en termes d'aménagement du
territoire
il me semble et c'est un des thèmes
principaux de ses provisions
ce qui nous importe c'est
qu'effectivement la desserte soit la
meilleure possible que ce soit par
l'avion ou par le rail alors quand vous
évoquez la question des coûts en dix ans
nous nous payons tous intégralement et
vous avez un concurrent encore plus
important qui s'appelle la route qui lui
ne paye rien et donc il faudra bien qu
effectivement un jour cette question
soit posée dans des termes clairs pour
qu'on parle de véritable concurrence non
faussée parce que cette concurrence
loyale et non faussée on peut
s'apercevoir qu'elle n'existe quasiment
elle n'existe quasiment dans aucun
domaine
j'ai encore une question si le président
veut bien je voudrais vous poser une
question et qui n'a rien de de
polémiquer ni d'anecdotique
c'est pour vous quelles sont les limites
du low cost c'est à dire de la baisse
des coûts eu égard à la sécurité aux
conditions de travail des salariés
on a évoqué dans low cost par exemple
des avions sans siège jusqùà peut-on on
ne peut-on pas aller
tout cela pour baisser à tout prix les
coûts je veux dire que la tendance il a
tendance de la baisse des coûts c'est
d'arriver à zéro autrement dit au
gratuit
quelles sont les limites de l'exercice
quelles sont les limites de la ligue de
l'exercice merci de vos réponses bien
six volumes alors jean luc fichet oui
merci monsieur le président écoutez moi
j'avoue va tout l ignorance en matière
de transport aérien
mais par contre ce que je voudrais c'est
témoigner d'une chose si vous dire que
le jeu prendre l'avion
toutes les semaines à brest guipavas
donc on a un aéroport qui est tout neuf
qui est inauguré il ya 4 5 ans été
construit par la ccit puis l'argent
public et on avait des conditions
d'accès à nos avions qui étaient tout à
fait correct jusqu'à il ya un mois c'est
con accéder à des avions par la
passerelle et bond des réservations on
avait de la place
dès que les conditions de transport
était vraiment bonne
depuis le mois de novembre nous n'avons
que des petits avions
c'est à dire que les finistériens
accèdent à des avions vous savez je
connais pas les noms des avions je vous
dis je
mais en voilà donc ça veut dire que les
passerelles pour nous c'est fini on
descend sur la piste on va à pied et
donc en plus au mois ça fait trois fois
que l'on retrouve sur listes d'attentes
en général les avions nous dit de bien
comprendre que il l'avion avoir à dix
minutes un quart d'heure de retard parce
que les cabines sont pas nettoyés ou
parce qu'il rassemble deux choses comme
ça qui se produisent ce qui crée comme
une vraie gêne ne prenez pas ça c'est
parce que souvent on a des rendez-vous
qui correspondent à des leds de temps de
de transport et donc on et vous savez en
train de réduire le temps de trains
entre paris et rennes ce qui fait que
par exemple moi qui fus morlaisien d'ici
quelques temps j'aurai un accès un pari
en moins de trois heures et demie
et je pense que nombreux seront les gens
qui comme moi feront le choix du train
parce qu'effectivement on aujourd'hui
l'avion n'offrent plus je dirais
satisfaction en termes de qualité de
prise en charge et transforme d'autant
qu'on a connu des conditions bien
meilleures avant le mode de vente de
placements ci c'est une situation
transitoire c'est quelque chose qui va
continuer et vous faire part quand même
du fort mécontentement qui est exprimé
toutes les semaines par les voyageurs
habitués qui prennent ces lignes merci
monsieur jacques théron dans nos camps
oui bonjour le pdg simplement dans votre
politique commerciale j'ai observé qu'il
y à une demande forte envers les dom
notamment la matinée que venait de
charles de gaulle
est-ce que vous avez un projet là dessus
je dis ça parce que dans le cadre d'un
agenda 21 territoriale avec le canada
est à une vingtaine de villes que nous
ferons temps régulièrement et disent
qu'ils ont du mal à transiter par
exemple par charles de gaulle parce que
sur les c'est compliqué bien je crois
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
suis super métier monsieur le président
je voudrais vous demander si on peut
évoquer un petit peu la transition
écologique et si on peut parler un petit
peu de 7
nécessaire évolution qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qui peut se
passer sur le carburant qui s'en fait
cette transition écologique font par un
petit peu cette commission qui est en
charge de l'environnement
donc si vous pouvez nous en dire un mot
quels sont vos réflexions auxquelles
sont vous vous idée là dessus
alors est ce que nous risquons une op à
air france klm par les intérêts non
européens jeu
actuellement ce n'est pas possible en
terminant en termes juridiques comme
vous le savez les intérêts des européens
ne peuvent pas en plus de 40 9% fin plus
de 50 pendant une entreprise européenne
limite juridique
voilà pour l'audition du président
directeur général d'air france alexandre
de juniac
vous pourrez la revoir à tout instant
sur notre site publicsenat.fr très bonne
matinée à tous sur public sénat
à